they started at his political opponents
but they say they will leave office as
close friends for the past eight years
Barack Obama and Joe Biden have been an
inseparable political duo they have seen
the country and each other through the
best and worst time in a conversation
the vice president gets personal about
his boss talk just finally about the
friendship with President Obama what it
he is well you know it was the
connection because he clearly clearly
relies on you well first of all he jokes
and he says you know we make up for each
other shortcomings he makes up for a lot
more my shortcomings than I do here's
number one number two though what did he
mean by our styles are so different and
well as our experience and so when he
asked me to join him I asked him why say
I want you to help me govern because you
know the system whomever the next
president is should have somebody they
trust they know will have their back
they understand their vice president and
every candid and will be candid with
them and the deal we made when when we
did this he said you have any conditions
I said jokingly I said two things a lot
were any funny hats and I'm not going to
change my brand and so the one and we
hollered each other and private means we
just like two friends and we hadn't had
an advantage though our families are
close um my granddaughter's are the very
best friends of his daughters
I'll Kahlua this he always kids me I'm
always saying all politics is personal
by that I mean if you understand the
other man's hopes aspirations fears the
president I we know each other we talked
we have lunch every week probably 64 the
time we talk about our families he was
there for my son he was the only one
when my son was dying that I was able to
be completely candid with and you could
talk to him I can't talk to him and I
felt obliged I had to delet him know
what was going on he was and he was
so he he was genuinely moved and Joe
what do you need so it's it's a it's a
genuine friend I respect him he has more
backbone more character than any one
person and a lot of President of
character than any president I've dealt
with the last eight presidents I trust
him and you said that I've taken way
more time your entire staff hates me no
but you told me Charlie I injure you
honest airily too so I get right with
them I think you're the best pal I mean
is an actual conversation I appreciate
that
Thank You vice president thank you
appreciate it please what a nice wait
and I love you say that the staff hates
me but you told me take as much time to
be clear fellas he said take this on Wow
what a beautiful beautiful relationship
that President Obama and Vice President
Biden had and and the fact that he's
talked about how at the toughest point
in his entire life yeah person who was
there that he could talk to was the
president you know he said that they
holler at each other so they clearly
have this strong professional
relationship but they are like brothers
they're like brothers almost like best
friends and they trust each other that's
it and you heard that at the eulogy that
the president gave up oh that's right
yes that's a really really good
interview know somebody who has your
back yeah I can't put a price on that